[MUSIC]
What advice do you have for
choosing recommenders?
>> I don't know if applicants really
appreciate how important the letters of
reference are.
>> Yeah.
>> It's really the one opportunity that we
get to see you through someone
else's eyes objectively.
What did you do and how did you do it?
So for me, put a lot of emphasis
on making the selection,
I can give you some tips
on how to think about it.
At Stanford we request two, in one we
ask for a current direct supervisor, or
the best alternative,
if that is impossible or inappropriate.
And for the second recommendation,
we also ask for
someone who's supervised your work,
but it could be from a nonprofit,
it could be extracurricular,
or from the same organization.
And when you think about selecting them
what you really, just as I've asked
applicants in their essays to tell us
about the impact that they've had,
because this past behavior
will predict future behavior,
that's the echo that we
want to see in a reference.
So find someone who know's what you've
done, really been in the trenches and
can see your work, and to describe not
just what happened but how you did it, and
how the way you did it might
have been different from others.
So that means don't worry
about the tittle of a person,
don't try to get the highest tittle.
Also, I hear a lot of students asking,
or applicants asking,
should I try to find someone who went
to Stanford because that's important?
No it's not.
It's actually what the recommender can
tell us about you that is most important.
The second thing is,
after them understanding what you've done,
is enthusiasm.
>> Yeah.
>> [LAUGH] This is a hard, for
someone who reads lots of
thousands of recommendations.
>> Right.
>> This one's a hard one to wrap your
hands around, but I know the best
recommendations that I read are written
from both a head space and a heart space.
>> Right.
>> So
try to think about who you have
established a relationship with.
Someone who really,
enthusiasm's a great word, but
has a connection with you, and
will be able to speak to that.
And that's how recommendations
become most memorable.
And then lastly, I think applicants
should think about the process.
Don't ask for
a recommendation in an email.
It's going to take this person
a significant amount of time.
On average,
our references are about two pages.
I'm guessing people have to spend at least
an hour or two to do a good job on them.
What is most disappointing to me when I'm
really looking to find reasons to admit,
is I'll get to the end of an application,
I'll be on the second recommendation, and
I'll see someone,
everything's been so positive and
they'll write a positive recommendation,
but maybe only two paragraphs.
And just say, they're phenomenal, they're
the best ever, they've done a great job,
but I won't have any of that
data to help me make a decision.
And it just means that this particular
applicant doesn't have as much,
I don't know, data, I guess is
the best word, but landscape for
me to really understand what they've
done and how they've done it.
So take it seriously, make an appointment,
even if it's a 15 minuet chat, but
ask the question courageously, and say,
will you write it, explain why, where
you're going, what schools, but then say,
do you have time to invest
to do a good job on this?
And if someone says they're really busy,
that's a good indication that maybe
you should go to your second choice.
because it can make a difference in
the end of how much they're willing to
spend time to help you on this process.
>> And then for the recommenders,
are there any resources for them or
how do they know how to write their
applicant the best letter they can?
>> [LAUGH] That's a great question.
We try to give, and many recommenders
have written more than one before, but
we try to give them clear advice and tips.
When they're invited onto our portal
on the website, the questions will ask
how has this person differentiated himself
from others that they've seen doing
similar roles, and what have they done and
accomplished, so they'll get that.
And, I think it comes down to that
they're willing to take the time to
really support you.
There's no magic there, but
they do have to make the investment and
be close enough to you to be able to write
thoughtfully about what you've done.